green felt the contact
gets it to go and won this is what he
learned in the g league watch this
he's going to keep the defender on his
back see that the defender can never
that's why aau tournaments are so great
out here because you have those
kids that are hungry those teenagers all
you can eat christopher
yeah that kid's got some confidence
let's see if he can get to the basket
shot clock is off
game clock is down to six jalen green
with hands on his hip gets it
[Applause]
and that'll do it for the first quarter
the number two overall pick
slithering through the defense so smooth
on the wing for three is good kyrie
thomas that young man played with mick
cronin at cincinnati
and that was not his forte jaylen green
with a step back three
green with a nice no-look path but
shingoon can't finish
you like it already we know he can score
what does he do in pick and roll
cut off by stevens but he still finds a
way to make it go
he's a born scorer he's the number three
overall pick
but then jalen greene can't stop me
steven silas is coming up he knows
basketball's pickled
matt hurt matthew heard one of the great
high school players in the country a
couple years
ago and all of a sudden fighting for a
career in the nba foster with the
floater
shane look he's calling for it that's
the screen for green
step back three he has got that shot
yeah chuck chuck daley used to say
what will the player do when the play
breaks down because the play always
breaks down
the block is mobile he's stripped
rockets have numbers three on two
christopher takes it himself and he is
found 18 to five
houston run dating back to the second
quarter
jalen green curling off the screen
knocks down two threes in a row here we
go
against an elite defender
matthew hurt needs a sneaker right now
they're playing five up four on five
christopher in and out with the fade
away jumper this guy
has cut the crowd mobley get touches and
that's what he's doing
six point lead for houston jaylen green
dancing with the ball
up against stevens another step back
that is
his signature move already jaylen green
thinks he's the best player out here
that's that's
perfect footwork right there jalen hans
who has
always had that speed
you know greens going right back to the
bucket he's gonna get
the finish for two he's got 23 points
already
this kid he got game underneath the shot
blocker
crafty as he physically physically
figures everything out
evan mobile
yep and that's the pick and roll iq i
wanted to see from
jalen green bars international kids
outlet pass to jalen green
finds that three-point line knocks down
his first three with a houston rocket
shangun fakes the handoff look at him
just
running through bodies to finish